we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's a
voicemail i received it call you a david
pakman you're an idiot man i just wanna
show here you aren't you you're part of
the decay of Western civilization
jackass yeah okay Darla I'm part of the
problem here Pat convinced it ghetto
obsolete yeah I'm the problem with or
the decay of Western civilization and
not uh any of the people I've spoken
about on today's show will this person
be pleased by the election results or
will this person be angry about the
election results we will see very soon
won't we on the bonus show today you can
buy citizenship in eight countries a lot
of people say if x candidate wins I'm
moving to Canada Canada's a tough one to
move to but there are eight countries
where if you have enough money you can
actually buy citizenship and we will
talk about that North Korean leader Kim
jong-un is not wasting the opportunity
of the United States election to
threaten the incoming US president with
a missile launch that is going to be
something that I am sure is going to be
taken more seriously than Kim jong-un
would actually like and number three we
will talk about live election coverage
that we will be doing on the bonus show
today remember the david pakman show
2017 calendars are available at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 you can get
just the calendar if you want and i will
autograph it for you if you like or if
you've been thinking about getting a
David Pakman show membership and of
course that includes access to the bonus
show and so many other great member
benefits will send you the calendar for
free if you sign up at david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 all the information is
there and you will get instant access to
today's bonus show the show doesn't have
to end now it can continue i encourage
you to sign up that is how this program
exists and we are on the air and
continuing to grow because of the
support of members I'll speak to you
then